*sifflement*
Bonjour les internautes!
Ça va?
On est ici pour quoi?
Le...
C'est quoi déjà ton jeu?
C'est pas Candy Crush que t'as.. ton jeu?
Je n'ai pas fait Candy Crush, je ne suis pas encore milliardaire
Pas du tout!
C'est la fin du Nope Quiz
La dernière mise à jour !
Exactement, c'est la toute dernière mise à jour
Donc si vous faites la mise à jour tout de suite vous pouvez terminer les 20 dernières questions
Et le niveau de la muerta...
C'est vingt nouvelles questions c'est ça?
Tu débloques un niveau de ouf à la fin, bref!
Un niveau de ouf, d'accord
Je te laisse appuyer sur le petit bouton
J'ai le droit d'en faire 20 cette fois?
Tu peux en faire dix, comme ça on laisse un peu la surprise aux autres
J'en fais 20 alors, parfait
Tu verras c'est encore très très fourbe
Par contre, c'est mon iPad donc ne le casse pas
C'est justeuuuuh
Effectivement, il y a marqué "Bonjour 6pri1"
Voilà, et pas "Squeezie"
Ooh, ce son me plait!
"Bienvenue dans la dernière mise à jour du Nope Quiz"
Oh bah c'est cordial
Oh mais c'est la cordialité
"Tu crois pouvoir terminer le jeu ?"
Bah comme les trois fois d'avant finalement
"C'est impossible!"
C'est faux!
Question 81, c'est parti !
Lequel de ces pays n'existe pas ? ARGHH
Un petit peu de géographie
J'suis nul a chier en géo mec,
C'est vrai?
Mais je sais que pour voir si il reste de l'électricité dans une pile
Il faut la mettre sur sa langue
C'est pas de la géographie
Ça n'a rien à voir avec la géographie
J'suis sûr y'a un truc très proche d'un vrai pays mais que t'as mal orthographié, ça je le sens
Mais mec, y'en a trop!
Alors, le Rukméristan
Bien évidemment
Le Ghirménistan
Non
Bah oui
Le "Monslipistan"
*rire*
Excellent !
Le Tadjikistan
Tadjiki c'est une sauce nan?
"Tza-tzi-ki, de blini"
Ah nan je viens d'insulter des gens qui vivent dans un pays
Ahahaha
Le Eminemstan, ça c'est... Ah bah voilà!
Tatatata tata tahaaa
Tainanainnanain
Voilà tu connais
Y'a un jeu de mot Eminem - Stan dans la musique
Tu t'y connais en géographie ! C'est faux
Trouve le chemin le plus court
Ok calcul en cours, calcul en cours
Déjà est-ce qu'un mec en France passera autant de temps que moi sur cette question?
En fait, il y a des gens qui calculent et ils y arrivent et parfois il y a des mecs ils se disent spontanément "paf" ! Tu vois et ça marche
C'est toi? Non c'est ton pote?
C'est le développeur du jeu putain
Dans les derniers niveaux, puis il étrangle un peu tout le...
J'ai cassé ton IPad aussi à mi-temps
Non mais tu sais pourquoi je suis pas chaud, attend je...
J'ai pas fais mon petit rituel
Enfin , en vrai je l'ai fait mais c'est le jus nectar d'orange de Leader Price
ça c'est ta came ça?
ça c'est ma came
En fait la dedans y'a de la pêche, ça stimule les neurones
Et de la cocaïne
Et de la cocaïne aussi apparemment
Bah du coup j'ai eu deux fautes donc en vrai j'ai plus qu'une chance sur deux
Attention
Bon voilà, buvez nectar pêche-orange
C'est dur mec de se rendre compte
Tu l'as plus ton petit doigt de la muerta?
Nan je l'ai plus, mais je vais te le caller tu vas voir ça va te surprendre
Regarde, je vais même pas lire la question, j'vais appuyer au pif, est-ce que t'es prêt?
Ah naaaan
J'ai tenté
Lis la question
Lequel de ces sports existe?
Hockey sous l'eau, patin sur gazon, lancer d'iPhone, 100 mètres haie sur glace
Vous le savez peut-être derrière votre écran?
Mais genre c'est reconnu?
J'ai dis une phrase de... Genre de télévision quoi
Cyprien Foucault
Cyprien Foucault, n'hésitez pas à jouer, le numéro s'affiche ici pour jouer
Envoyez "téton" bien sûr
Par sport tu veux dire que c'est reconnu par l'Etat?
Pas par l'Etat, mais que en tout cas il y a des fédérations
Y'a une fédération, au moins une fédération
Du 100 mètres haie sur glace
C'est évident...
NAAAAANNN
Putain mais mec
Bah du coup c'est... Naaan
En fait, je l'ai ouvert et j'ai pas bu, je sais pas si t'as remarqué
Ah ouai c'est vrai
J'ai pas bu
Bah du coup c'est le hockey sous l'eau
Mais comment tu peux faire du hockey sous l'eau?
Le hockey subaquatique a été inventé dans les années 50...
Ah d'accord, mais c'était vraiment y'a 60 ans quoi...
"J'ai essayé personnellement le lancer d'iPhone, j'ai regretté amèrement."
Faut jamais euh.... Non, vraiment fais pas ça
Mais, comment tu joues au hockey subaquatique ?
Oh Put**n, Oh Put**n, on sera là bientôt on sera assis ici
Il y a pas foule hein ?
Faites du bruit !
Y'a pas foule foule hein ?
Faites du bruit pour nos champions !
Put**n ! Ils ont des petites euh.. C'est quoi, c'est un couteau en plastique ?
C'est pour retirer le givre sur ta voiture le matin *rire*
Y'a un mec qui a regardé ça il a fait : put**n,va trouver un tuba, je te fait un sport
Ça n'a pas de sens, le palet est beaucoup trop petit quoi !
Regarde les mecs on dirait des...
Tu reconnais même pas ton équipe tu sais
En fait, moi ce qui me fait mourir de rire, c'est qu'ils ont quand même une chanson rock'n'roll
T'sais genre faut être un bad guy et tout pour faire ça
Mec, je veux faire une vidéo où je fais du hockey subaquatique
C'est incroyable
Bon allez
Ah put**n
Je te remercie pour cet instant de bonheur
Tu m'as dit que... euuuuh...
J'aimais le piano ?
T'aimais le piano !
Oh ! Reproduisez la symphonie "I gotta Feeling" du groupe philarmonique Black Eyed Peas
...Avec ce grand piano de concert
Tintintintin tintintintin tintintintin
C'est ça ?
Tintintintintin
5 !
(4)
4 ! 4 !
NAN ! J'en ai fait 5, pardon pardon
Attends, attends, attends
ATTENDS ATTENDS
Je stress
Il m'a dit qu'il avait acheté un piano donc..
Nan mais ça c'est déjà le...
Ca c'est au bout d'un an que tu sais faire ça
Ah le mec ! Pas du tout !
OK J'ai !
Ooooooooooooooh !!!
"'Cause tonight's gonna be a good night
T''es content ?
43-14... alors je suis très fort en mathématiques
Ca fait bien évidemment 29 hein
C'est quoi la blague attends ?
Égal ?
Doigt magique !
Quoi ??
10... 15... 4
Ca fait 29 !
Ooooooooooooooooooooooooh !!
Tu l'avais pas vu venir mon pote
J'ai, j'ai créé le jeu donc euh j'ai plutôt vu...
Eh les mecs qui savent jouer "I gotta feeling" au piano, ils surprennent tout le temps les autres, je te jure
Oh, c'est quoi ? C'est quoi ?
On regarde la pub également
Ah bah c'est la pub la plus euh... la plus fluide que j'ai vue
C'est quoi, c'est pour l'armée de Terre ou un truc comme ça non ?
Pas du tout !! Ca s'arrête !
On sait même pas
On saura pas
Merci d'avoir payé cher annonceur pour cette vidéo incroyable
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de moi ?
-Tu m'inquiètes
-Aucun avis...
Je trouve qu'il est très séduisant
Put**n, c'est bon t'as commencé à comprendre comment il fonctionnait
Aaaah, c'est l'inverse de... Ok
Alors, c'est bien sûr, (ça te rappelle quelque chose ?)
c'est bien sûr une girafe !
Moi je dirais que là dedans; c'est un ours
Bon vas-y, l'éléphant !
T'es vraiment une sal*******pe !
Parce que, oui ! Oui oui remember !
Quel est cet animal ?
Girafe ? Éléphant ? Chauve-souris ? Mante religieuse ?
Franchement on dirait une girafe, mais je sais qu'il y a un piège
Bon éléphant ?
Comment peut-on se tromper à cette question, mec ?
Baaaaaaah mec, en fait un jour j'ai joué à un jeu, je sais plus
Il était pas ouf le jeu d'ailleurs, et c'était genre, une blague là-dessus
Où genre c'était un éléphant et en fait dedans, il y avait un autre animal
Déjà faire une blague là-dessus, paye ton humour !
Ouais c'était vraiment pas ouf
Relie ces personnalités à leur vrai prénom
Je crois que Joey Starr c'est Didier en vrai
Chuck Norris ? Attends
Ah j'ai pas envie de perdre
Bon mec en vrai je sais pas donc on va dire Vin Diesel il a une tête de Carlos
Donc j'ai dis, Joey Starr c'est Didier, Vin Diesel c'est bien sûr Eric
Bah bien sûr c'est faux
C'est bien sûr Marc
Jamie Foxx quant à lui, c'est bien sûr...
Il a bien bien une tête de Carlos
Chuck Norris s'appelle en vrai Carlos
Aaah oui ! Quand j'ai vu que Chuck Norris s'appelait Carlos,  j'ai fait :
Je veux faire une question sur ce truc là
Ohhhh ! C'est incroyable !
OK DERNIÈRE QUESTION !!
Ferme ta gueule
"La réponse est à l'envers"
Alors est-ce que la réponse est :
"A l'envers" ?
Est-ce qu'elle est à l'envers genre horizontalement ?
Ou est-ce qu'elle est à l'envers verticalement  et horizontalement ?
Ou alors est-ce qu'elle est à l'envers juste verticalement ?
Ooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooh !
Il a compris du premier coup
Effectivement il fallait retourner
Put**n mec !
Je peux voir la fièreté dans tes yeux !
Ah nan maaaaaais
C'est bon tu peux revenir à l'endroit maintenant
Mec ! Je suis choqué, c'est trop bien ! En plus je me disais "bah ça va rien faire"
Mais peut-être que mon cerveau va comprendre un truc
Effectivement, de le retourner ça te...
Et là du coup ça débloque..
Eh ben super alors, ensuite !
Hop hop hop hop
Ah naaaaaan mais naaaaaaan !!!
J'en ai marre, après aussi je...
Ça t'a plus ?
C'était super cool, j'ai beaucoup apprécié
C'est marrant parce que ça montre que... nos cerveaux sont pas pareils
Genre moi par exemple il y a des questions où je vais galérer, d'autres vont pas galérer
Il y en a d'autres, pour retourner l'iPad pour valider la question, pour eux c'est... C'est
Tu vois c'est pas possible
Donc c'est marrant de voir un peu les, tu vois les cerveaux qui fonctionnent...
C'est marrant de voir que j'ai pas de culture ?
Est-ce que tu veux... Je t'offre un moment, où tu peux remercier qui tu veux, fais une dédicace, parce que tu passes sur cette chaine
On se croirait à la radio
Vas-y fais tes dédicaces, allez vite
On dirait que je suis chez Arthur
Le quiz est terminé, il y a les 100 questions, et à la fin, vous allez débloquer un mode spécial
Pour pouvoir jouer à toutes les questions d'un coup en aléatoire pour faire un maximum de points
Vous allez voir, le truc est assez ouf, ça s'appelle ???
ET surtout il y a un moment un peu tendre avec le Patrick, avec le présentateur
A la fin il nous parle tu vois et c'est un moment que j'aime beaucoup donc euh,
N'hésitez pas à télécharger pour terminer cette dernière mise à jour
Le jeu est terminé, et du coup je ne peux faire qu'un gros big up à vous d'y avoir joué
Merci Lucas, merci à ceux qui ont bossé dessus bien évidemment
Jérémie qui a développé, qui a fait les musiques (Un mec en or)
Etienne qui a fait tous les graphismes et les animations (un mec en diamant)
Et notre ami Simon (Un mec en bronze) qui a fait les dessins
Donc Patrick si vous le détestez c'est à cause de Simon
Et Vincent Tirel qui m'a aidé à écrire des questions (un mec en plaqué or)
Donc, je suis super fier d'avoir terminé
Eh bah bravo, moi j'applaudis
Bravo, c'est la fin du Nope Quiz, (Je suis super content) moment émotion. Il y a des confettis qui tombent
Bravo Cyprien, bravo pour ce projet
(J'ai fait un jeu ! J'ai fait un jeu !)
Tu as gagné le cadre(Oh! Wouah!) Un million de téléchargement,c'est pour toi bien sûr !(Incroyable!)
La meilleure question c'est aussi pour toi bien sûr(Wouah!Merci!)